- The first time,
when I was very little,
we were in Houston.
Yes, I think it was Houston.
And at some point,
they have such good food.
But at some point,
we were craving tacos.
And it was one of the
first times that we went.
I was still very young.
And we saw Taco Bell, you know?
(Kelly laughs)
And let's go get some tacos.
And can we have two meat tacos?
And our English was not very well.
And they gave us the shell tacos.
I've never seen that in my life.
They don't exist in Mexico.
It's always with the soft tortilla.
And we're like, "No, no, no."
"We want tacos."
"And yeah, this is."
"No, tacos, no."
And we're asking each other,
"How do you say tacos in English?"
(Kelly and the audience laugh)
I don't know the name of
the place is Taco Bell.
And I'm like,
"Okay, taco, taco, taquito."
"You roll it." (munching)
"This is hard."
"It's not like this."
"No taco. This is no taco."
And turns out, that's a Texan taco.
- It's,
- [Salma] That, you know.
- Yes.
- [Salma] Like Tex-Mex taco.
- Tex-Mex.